I just wanted to say one thing I know a
lot of our conversation is focused in on
accountability for women but at least
like I said earlier like if you're a
dude and you're unaccountable out here I
have I'm not sorry for you like I'm not
sorry for you I don't care at all and
guess what the world doesn't care right
the world doesn't care if you fail and
then you don't pick up the pieces the
world doesn't care if she cheated on you
and you didn't improve on yourself the
world doesn't care if you're scared of
failure the world doesn't care the world
doesn't care they will never care you
have to be a man within your own right
within your own masculinity to pick up
the pieces solution for yourself to
create the life that you want the world
doesn't care they care about women They
Don't Care About Us all right so work on
yourself and continue